foreign
and talk to the great Leah what's up
Leah
hi how's it going
okay to send out my kid has struck
wonderful oh how can I get it over the
phone just kidding I'm so sorry that's
tough it's okay it's the life of a mom
right that's right is it the last week
of school or you got a couple weeks left
all right I'm so sorry yeah well how can
I help
uh basically I've been trying to figure
out how to phrase this question but I
think this is the best way I can phrase
it just Cannonball just jump in just
jump in
uh I've been with my boyfriend for six
months now I know it's not very long but
I'm like if we can get married right now
I would totally do let's do it let's
just get married right now I'm like
ready for this but
his kids are completely traumatized by
me and I can't like talk about them he
can't talk about me in front of them
like my name's like a cuss word why I
can't why why are you mean
no the nature of the way they found out
wasn't exactly good he didn't tell them
about me they found out about me where's
their mom
they live with their mom it's basically
the way they found out about me because
I mean my boyfriend is still technically
married they're just separated
so Leah why
I'm so sorry
what are you doing
isn't that why I called James just to
tell me what to do
you have your own kids
three
how old are you
31.
why are you dating a married man
it does it does and I don't think you do
I think you love the idea I think you
love the idea of him
oh
are you the reason they broke up
[Music]
him yeah no guy has ever in the history
of husbands said no hey we're actually
we're on the way to getting divorced so
it's okay
a year yeah I believe that kids are
still in
Illinois and everything
Leah you know
this is insane you know
come on you know that his story is not
true and you're going along with me
genuinely believe there is zero percent
chance none no chance at what he's
saying is true none zero
couples who are getting divorced don't
go well you can go ahead and just hook
up with other people and we'll just ride
this out for a year or more and then
we'll go no what are you talking about
if you feel like I have to separate from
you I can't be married to you anymore
you start a process
what he has told you is absolutely
untrue and I know that you know that
right I don't I don't think it's untrue
I just don't understand that like why
right now since they're already
separated he can't just
go through because he hasn't told them
he hasn't told them he has he has no he
told his wife that he cheated on you on
her that's what he told her when you are
the secretary found out he didn't tell
her there you go when you are the secret
you are the secret
honey you are worth so much more than
the life you're settling for
this guy sucks
though he does and you are falling in
his heels real close
it's not cool man of course his kids
don't want to be around you his kids
have the or under the illusion that Mom
and Dad are going to get back together
they're gonna work it out
I even he says that they are saying that
they're okay with them not being
together but I've
tried to like talk to him about it to be
like I don't understand if this is what
you were gonna do anyway let me let me
promise you this I'm afraid of them
being hurt he doesn't want them to be
hurt he doesn't want them to be
traumatized even further by me but he
wants to sleep with you though
he wants both
so let me be super clear this will
happen to you you're going to be The
Other Woman at some point too
oh my God
period
how old are your kids Leah
seven six and ten months is this the
picture you're drawing up for them of
what love looks like
what romance looks like
and what honesty and
respect and dignity looks like
I do
really would like to have us eventually
actually like
be together out there in front of people
it's not gonna happen it's not gonna
happen why not why is finna can happen
because you are
Mary you were you were falling for
somebody
in the haze of baby number three
you have fallen for somebody
in the haze of the fear of being alone
you have fallen for somebody who does
not tell the truth who lies to his
children who lies to his current wife
who lies to his girlfriend
who lies to his girlfriend's kids
and is trying to keep every spinning
plate going
and it will all come down
and even if he chooses you over his wife
and his kids
what is that you want to be with that
guy
please no that's the other
of any time they need anything or want
anything he just goes and does it and do
it no no I'm saying let's say he goes
through with this that he hurts his kids
even though he doesn't want to hurt him
he just wants to sleep with this other
lady but he wants everything to be fine
and good and so we're just going to keep
it secret
and maybe this divorce that him and his
wife have been working on for a long
time but they just agreed to it's cool
you can just hook up other people and
we'll just keep living together and be
married for a year or or more
maybe he goes through with all that
and then he moves in with you and you'll
hold hands in public for the first time
and your three kids are trailing behind
and his two or three kids are trailing
behind your three kids and you have a
family of five or six and y'all are
sitting in a taco shop just having the
time of your life
and then some woman walks by and he
lingers a little bit too long and the
way he glances at her
and your body will remember this story
how you or her at one time
or the first time he turns his phone
over when you walk into the room
there is no way this thing plays out
Leah
and you wouldn't want to be with a guy
that walked out like that anyway
I don't know maybe you would maybe you
would
oh okay so then I
I'm probably the wrong guy to talk to
then because I mean I I like I I
my commitment is telling the truth even
when it's hard
and
also I'm committed to not sitting down
and watching a car wreck happen
he's not gonna he's he's just not an
honest person he's not a person of
integrity
you can still want to be with him all
you want and but you're not gonna be
able to be with him and not have
relational dysfunction all over the
place
it's impossible
because he is relationship dysfunction
and you are too
what are you getting from him
what am I getting
yeah what do you what do you get from
him
well I was
saying okay
to everything that this guy isn't he
actually takes care of me like
is that what I'm thinking how I'm
feeling he actually talks to me because
my last relationship he never spoke a
word to me he talks to you in secret and
private where no one can see or hear
and that's just until his kids are okay
everybody tells me
I was just worried about his kids and
protecting them and making sure they're
not
hurt he's not he's worried about his own
but
why why
so I'm like what do I have to just be
like either gonna like do this or it's
over or like what if you were my sister
are you one of my close friends that
I would tell you that the next phone
call should be hey look I I can't be in
your life
while you're still married
I can't be in your life as a ghost
I can't be the woman on the side
if I'm going to be in relationship with
somebody I'm going to be all in
not
10 or 4 because I'm worth way more than
that and I've been abused before and
I've been treated like garbage and I've
been told repeatedly I was nothing
and I'm not doing that anymore my kids
deserve better I deserve better
and so yeah when your marriage is over
and the divorce papers are signed
maybe I'll talk to you by then my head
might have cleared up a little bit from
the smoke of my abusive past and the
smoke of having a 10 month old and a
seven-year-old in the same house
which I've had that and it's it's
Madness it's Madness and then the only
difference between me and you is uh you
have a third one in there I didn't have
that yeah
so When the Smoke Clears on all that my
guess is you're going to want to have
nothing to do with a guy like this
but also I can't blame everything on him
no you can't
and you're a woman choosing to enter
into a family of a married man with kids
that are demonstrable how much they
think you're hurting their family
and you're like I just want to be with
him you can't do that I mean you can
but that means you lack Integrity too
many no I have problems nope nope nope
you can't just you can't just ride my
phone I just got problems no you're
making choices
you're gonna have to heal from what
happened to you the hell you've lived
through before you just jump right into
another swimming pool
because you haven't learned how to swim
yet you've learned how to not drown
and I don't even know
you can
it's gonna be awful it's gonna be awful
it's gonna be very hard
but over the long term you're going to
walk six six just taller
you're gonna have peace in your home for
the first time ever your kids are going
to know peace in their home your kids
are going to know a mother
who understands she's got strength and
she's not a person who lacks Integrity
doesn't tell the truth
and brings home guys who are just scum
of the Earth
you're just worth so much more
and if if if nobody else does your kids
and his kids do
God's sake Leah
don't I mean just be done with this
thing
that's the best I can tell you